Conventional wisdom or has had at the,
we have no teper source of electricity,
then call and impact the have no
reliable suffers.
And part of the reason we have that
belief system is because environmental
as have generally pushed when power and
for the world tykes which can be a small
percentage,
five,
10,
15,
maybe even 20% of our electricity supply
and that makes them huge markets.
But 10,
15,
20% of our supply is not a climate
change solution.
There are great investment opportunities
and we invest in them,
but we have to be clear they want solve
the climate change problem for that you
need something that can have the kind of
reliability,
independent ability call has.
You can sign a 20 year contract with the
utility and say something other than
I'll ship your power when the wind
blows.
It doesn't quite work for utility.
Uh,
there are newer technologies coming
along that solve that problem.
Do your terminal solves that problem.
You can deliver power when the utility
needs new kinds of technologies like
solar thermal and Florida just
announced,
uh,
the use of those technologies for a
massive solar project in Florida,
not considered a traditional solar
strength state.
These technologies can have what's
called dispatchable power.
When the utilities customers need power,
you can supply it to the utility so they
can supply it to their customers and not
make excuses like it's not sunny or the
wind doesn't blow.
And that kind of utility grade power,
power,
I call it punk power is absolutely key
to cracking call.
Not only that,
it has to be cheap enough.
Fortunately,
the cost of coal based power has been
going up.
Environmental Regulations for criteria
pollutants like sulfur dioxide in mode
creating have been getting more
stringent.
And because of that call now it costs
quite a lot more to preger coal based
power costs a lot more to produce than
it did five years ago or even two years
ago.
Uh,
that gives us an opportunity.
The coal industry is talking about next
generation coal power plant technology
called IGCC and IGCC carbon
sequestration is what they think is the
solution.
The so called clean called switch.
That solution should be attempted.
We should try it.
My personal belief is solar thermal
technologies and geothermal technologies
will be cheaper than those technologies.
And because they will be cheaper,
they'll beat them in the marketplace.
And we will,
uh,
find,
that we don't need as much coal for
power generation.
There are other good uses for calls,
so I'm not against cove,
but it shouldn't end up in our
atmosphere first.
You know,
I believe having watched technology
development over the last three to five
years,
that could a,
the biggest problem is having people
believe that we can replace oil with a
cheaper alternative.
That we can replace IGCC corn plants
with a cheaper source of power that are
more renewable,
100% renewable.
Having the world believe that is,
I think the biggest problem.
We still need to make more progress in
technology,
but I do believe it's a mostly solved
problems.